digamos que tienes una matriz a y nos
vamos a preguntar ahora quién es el
espacio nulo de esta matriz ah ok no
sabemos quién es el espacio nulo sin
embargo sabemos muy bien cómo
caracterizar la verdad simplemente
tomamos la ecuación a equis y buscamos
las soluciones de esta ecuación cuando
igualamos a 0 es decir tenemos la
ecuación homogénea verdad y entonces el
espacio nulo de nuestra matriz a son
todos estos x son todos los vectores x
verdad todos los x que satisfacen que es
que satisfacen satisfacen esa ecuación
de acá arriba que es la x igual a 0 muy
bien entonces una forma de hacerlo y
como ya lo hemos visto en en muchos
vídeos anteriores es simplemente tomamos
esta al poner la forma aumentada de la
matriz verdad aumentamos la matriz
poniendo de esta forma tenemos la matriz
a y además vamos a poner como columna a
este vector que es el vector
pero verdad entonces lo que hacemos
ahora es un montón pero un montón de
operaciones de tal suerte que del lado
izquierdo llegamos a la forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones la forma
reducida y es forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones de nuestra
matriz
y del lado derecho las operaciones que
hacemos a esta a esta matriz aumentada
en realidad no afectan al cero verdad
así que del lado derecho vamos a tener
al cero y bueno eso ya lo hemos visto en
varios vídeos y qué es lo que nos genera
esto esto es lo que lo que ocurre es que
entonces el vector x fíjense que aquí en
realidad lo que vamos a tener es que los
las soluciones x a la hora de regresar
esta forma reducida y escalonada a mis a
un sistema nuevo digamos a un sistema de
ecuaciones mevyt me dice que la solución
x será igual va a ser igual a pues
alguna constante digamos
a por un vector en uno más b por n 2 y
así sumamos varias veces hasta c n
sería en verdad el vector m y el enésimo
verdad y esto es digamos el generado en
realidad está a bs y bueno todas las
constantes que vayan aquí para cada uno
de estos vectores que obtenemos de
regresarlo al sistema
estas constantes lo que ocurre es que
son libres son libres entonces esto de
aquí lo que me genera porque al ser
libres estas constantes las aves y demás
generan todo un espacio y es el espacio
generado por n1 n2 n3 y así hasta nn
verdad entonces el espacio nulo de
nuestra matriz es el espacio vectorial
generado por n 1 n 2 y así hasta nn
verdad todo es este espacio vectorial
generado ahora vamos a tomar la pregunta
siguiente qué pasa en el caso en el caso
no homogéneo es decir qué pasa si
nosotros tenemos la ecuación
a equis igual a be ok donde ve ya no es
necesariamente el vector pero de hecho
no va a ser el vector cero ok entonces
ya sabemos también cómo resolver esto es
la misma idea tenemos nuestra matriz y
le aumentamos una columna que es el
vector b volvemos a llevar a su forma
reducida forma reducida y escalonada por
renglones de nuestra matriz a y aquí del
lado derecho pues ahora sí las
operaciones van a afectar a estévez
verdad vamos a obtener un vez distinto
digamos que vamos a obtener una prima
sale que es distinto esencialmente a ver
entonces qué es lo que está pasando
vimos también en el vídeo anterior vimos
también en el vídeo anterior que
entonces x el vector x lo vamos a poder
expresar cómo nuestro vector de prima ok
y de hecho este prima lo podemos
interpretar como una solución particular
verdad es una solución particular de
esta ecuación y que además le teníamos
que sumar esta solución al caso
homogéneo entonces es algo así de esta
forma n 1 + b n 2 y así sumamos hasta c
n n verdad ok entonces como dijimos en
el vídeo anterior
estévez prima de aquí era una solución
particular es una solución particular de
esta misma ecuación ok mientras que del
otro lado lo que tenemos lo que tenemos
aquí
y lo que tenemos aquí es una solución a
la ecuación homogénea ok con hd
homogéneo pd particular entonces tenemos
una solución a la homogénea y realmente
vimos esto en el vídeo pasado aunque no
lo demostramos rigurosamente no lo
demostramos rigurosamente lo que lo que
quiero hacer entonces es escribir esto
sale vamos primero a escribir este
enunciado lo que estamos afirmando aún
sin demostrar es que cualquier solución
cualquier solución al sistema al sistema
no homogéneo y por supuesto estamos
pensando en el sistema a x igual a b no
homogéneo ok
este el ax igual a b
y de hecho creo que ya me estoy saltando
un acento verdad aquí está homogéneo ok
cualquier solución al sistema no
homogéneo a x igual a b tomara una forma
particular de hecho es esta forma verdad
tomara la forma la forma siguiente que
lo podemos expresar como una suma de una
solución particular más una solución del
caso homogéneo ok entonces lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es dar una
demostración más rigurosa de esta
afirmación que acabamos de dar y aunque
va a ser si rigurosa también es cierto
que es muy directa y muy sencilla de
entender ok entonces lo que vamos a
hacer primero lo que vamos a hacer
primero es preguntarnos lo siguiente
será cierto que esta expresión una
solución particular más una solución
homogénea será cierto que esto es
solución solución a la ecuación x a x
igual a b porque el primero nos
preguntamos si al escribir algo de esta
forma será solución de este sistema
entonces qué pasa si sustituimos y en
vez de poner x ponemos esto entonces
vamos a tener a que multiplica a x p más
x
h ok utilizamos la linealidad y
separamos verdad esto es a xp más a por
x h verdad esto simplemente es
distribuyendo y lo que hay que notar es
que como xp es una solución particular
de esta ecuación ok entonces en
particular a xp ya perdón a xp debe ser
igual a b esto es igual a b por otro
lado xh es solución de la homogénea y
recordemos que el lazo que la homogénea
es cuando se resuelve esta ecuación es
decir a x en este caso será 0 en este
caso es 0 y si sumamos ve más h lo que
tenemos perdón además de más 0 pues lo
que tenemos es simplemente b entonces
este vector citó de aquí en efecto fue
una solución
si fue una solución de esta ecuación ok
entonces ya tenemos una parte ahora la
siguiente pregunta es bueno ya sabemos
que todas las las expresiones de esta
forma son solución la siguiente pregunta
es toda solución se puede expresar de
esta forma
vamos a escribir eso será cierto que
cualquier solución
quiere solución de que ecuación pues de
digamos cualquier solución x de la
ecuación a x igual a de toma la forma
toma la forma que antes mencionamos toma
la forma
xp más x h
y esto es aún una pregunta vamos a ver
si esto es cierto entonces tomémonos x
cualquier solución a x igual a b
ok cualquier solución
de el sistema de x igual a b
ok nos tomamos cualquier solución vamos
a tomarnos una arbitraria ok entonces
qué pasa qué pasa si nosotros
multiplicamos
digamos que tomamos a por x menos una
solución particular ok
qué pasa si tomamos esto que nos va a
dar bueno esto simplemente vamos a tomar
bueno distribuimos este producto y nos
queda a x menos
por xp verdad una solución particular
aquí lo único que hicimos fue restarle
una solución particular a x y después
multiplicarlo por a muy bien entonces
qué es lo que nos da a x menos a xp y
como esto era solución de x igual a b
pues esto vale b y como xp es una
solución particular de esta ecuación
pues también vale b entonces b - b pues
es simplemente 0 muy bien entonces lo
que podemos concluir es que x menos xp
pues al menos es una solución de
solución de quién
lo que hicimos fue sustituir en esta
ecuación y lo que nos dio fue 0 verdad
entonces x xp es solución a esta
ecuación lo cual quiere decir muchísimo
recordemos entonces que queremos buscar
una solución al sistema no homogéneo
verdad de hecho lo que queremos es ver
si dada cualquier solución de esta
ecuación se puede expresar como esta
suma lo que hicimos fue restarle una
solución particular y al multiplicarlo
por la matriz a resulta que nos dio 0
eso inmediatamente nos está diciendo que
este vector de aquí este vector de aquí
x xp pues tiene que ser un elemento del
espacio nulo entonces x menos xp es un
elemento es un elemento del espacio nulo
de nuestra matriz y eso es porque es la
solución de a x igual a 0 verdad o bien
en otras palabras ya habíamos dicho que
los elementos del espacio nulo pues son
las soluciones homogéneas
esto es x x p será igual a una solución
homogénea de la ecuación homogénea y
déjenme escribirlo para no perderlo de
vista este es una solución
solución como vamos a llamarle así como
gene
muy bien entonces ya esto es muy
sencillo porque si despejamos x
tendremos que x es igual a x h
una solución homogénea más una solución
particular ok y hay que remarcar que fue
para cualquier x solución no nos fijamos
en un en particular nos tomamos
cualquiera entonces aquí ya demostramos
en dos sentidos que sí es cierto que si
una solución se expresa de esta forma
entonces bueno si si tenemos una
expresión en este en esta forma existe
más x h entonces resulta ser solución y
por el otro lado cualquier solución se
expresa de esta forma entonces estamos
diciendo en los dos sentidos ahora
porque estoy tan interesado en esto
digamos que realmente ya me he detenido
un buen rato en esta ecuación la
homogénea esta de aquí
pero bueno hemos estado hablando de la
noción de transformaciones cuando son 1
a 1 recuerdan entonces voy a recordar la
noción de 1 a 1 y que de hecho era una
condición para que una transformación
fuera invertible y lo que recordamos es
que bueno si tenemos una transformación
que va de un espacio x a un espacio de
verdad tomamos una transformación y lo
que nos dice es que si esta
transformación va de un conjunto x a un
conjunto y lo que nos dice es bueno de
una vez vamos a hacerlo de la siguiente
forma porque estamos trabajando en rn y
rm entonces esta transformación asocia
vectores a la multiplicación de una
matriz por ese vector verdad entonces
para digamos escribir rápido si yo
quiero una transformación 1 a 1
es bastante cómo describirlo así pues lo
que me dice es que cualquier b si nos
tomamos cualquier elemento
en nuestro en nuestro espacio ya que
puede ser un algún rm entonces me dice
que hay y lo voy a poner a esto sí con
mayúsculas a lo más verdad a lo más una
una solución solución
la ecuación a x igual a b ok y remarco a
lo más porque podría no haber y está
bien si no hay sólo debe haber no más de
una ecuación de una solución perdón
entonces si yo me tomo un elemento b me
dice que voy a poder encontrar un punto
por aquí x ok
tal que al aplicarle la transformación
que de hecho no es otra cosa más que
multiplicar por una matriz voy a poder
voy a poder llegar a ver y que no debe
haber otro verdad si hay algún x solo
puede ser el único puede no haber y está
bien pues pero a lo más debe haber una
ok entonces
déjenme escribir un poquito aquí digamos
lo siguiente déjenme bajar un poco
entonces tenemos que cualquier solución
cualquier solución
cualquier solución y recordemos puede no
haber pero sí si la hay
tenemos que cualquier solución se
expresa de la forma x p más x h verdad
solución particular más una de la
homogénea entonces aquí por supuesto
estamos pensando que nuestra solución
homogénea pues es un elemento del
espacio nulo de nuestra matriz verdad
eso es lo que siempre hemos estado
diciendo y si debe ser si esto tiene que
ser a lo más
una solución que sólo puede ser una
solución que de hecho no tiene sentido
que póngalo más verdad
sí sí estamos diciendo que este es una
solución entonces
de hecho de hecho sólo puede ser una
solución solo
puede ser
una solución que está ya es una solución
y sólo puede ser una que me está
diciendo esto fíjense que si yo sumo
otro elemento del espacio nulo al
multiplicar por la matriz que me queda a
x xp que es ve a por x h que 0 y si
sumamos otro digamos h que esté en el
espacio nulo me queda a por gh es cero
entonces 0 + 0 + b sigue siendo ven en
realidad si yo sumo cualquier elemento
del espacio nulo sigue siendo otra
solución otra solución distinta verdad
entonces lo que necesitamos es que no
podamos sumar muchas otras cosas así que
para no poderle sumar muchas otras cosas
x h sólo puede ser un vector y de hecho
tiene que ser el vector 0 verdad eso ya
lo habíamos incluso discutido en algún
vídeo anterior que el núcleo o el
espacio nulo sólo puede constar del 0
que si hubiera algún otro elemento pues
podemos ir sumando elementos del espacio
nulo y siguen siendo soluciones verdad
entonces vamos a ir escribiendo todos
estos detalles porque si tenemos una
transformación que es 1 a 1 ok de hecho
si el espacio nulo sólo consta de esto
verdad vamos a poder tener que es 1 a 1
entonces qué es lo que ocurre con esto
si sino si consideramos la matriz de la
siguiente forma que tiene sus vectores
columnas a1 a2 y así sucesivamente hasta
a n que éste es nuestra matriz y
multiplicamos al vector x digamos x 1 x
2 y así hasta el x n y esto pues
queremos que sea 0 verdad si es que
quise es un elemento del espacio nulo
pues esto debe ser igual a igual a puros
ceros ok entonces qué es lo que ocurre y
es lo que vimos ya hace varios vídeos
que esto es equivalente a multiplicar x
1 por a uno más x 2 por a 2 y así
sucesivamente hasta x n por a n donde
cada una de las x es una es una
constante y esto tiene que ser igual al
vector 0 pero eso qué significa
si yo me si yo quiero que el espacio en
uno solo consta del cero quiere decir
que todas estas x deben ser cero
necesariamente
eso sí recordarás bueno tenemos que x 1
debe ser igual x 2 deben ser todas
iguales y deben ser iguales a 0 y eso no
es otra cosa más que la definición de
que estos vectores los los vectores así
sean linealmente independientes entonces
esto me va a implicar que a 1 a 2 y así
sucesivamente hasta a n son linealmente
mente independientes es justo la
definición de que sean linealmente
independientes independientes ok
entonces
entonces si son linealmente
independientes quiere decir que de hecho
mi espacio columna que es el espacio
vectorial generado justamente por los
por los vectores columna que es a1 a2 y
así hasta a n todos estos en realidad si
estos vectores son linealmente
independientes
todos estos son linealmente
independientes y recordemos que lo que
estoy buscando es tener una única
solución para lo cual esta solución
particular perdón esta solución de la
homogénea solo puede ser el vector cero
y aquí me falta ponerle su gorrito
entonces solo puede ser el vector cero y
si eso es cierto quiere decir que éstos
tienen que ser linealmente
independientes por lo cual como son
linealmente independientes y generan al
espacio columna quiere decir que todos
estos a 1 a 2 y así sucesivamente hasta
a n forman son o son una base verdad son
una base
el espacio columna de nuestra matriz ok
y si son una base y cuantos tenemos
dijimos que tenemos n entonces la
dimensión del espacio columna de nuestra
matriz es justamente n que es el
qué es la dimensión de nuestro dominio
verdad es justo la dimensión de nuestro
dominio y esto no es otra cosa más que
el rango de nuestra matriz pues tiene
que ser n entonces fíjense que ya
llegamos a la situación en que una
transformación es 1 a 1 si la dimensión
del espacio columna verdad la dimensión
del espacio columna es n muy bien es n
que es justo la dimensión de nuestro
dominio entonces fíjense que es si solo
si uno es una transformación es uno a
uno sí solo si el rango de la matriz es
n por ejemplo si tenemos que el rango de
la matriz es n quiere decir que la
dimensión de su espacio columna es n
quiere decir que sus vectores columna
son una base del espacio columna verdad
que es el espacio vectorial que generan
y si son linealmente independientes
quiere decir que esta ecuación se cumple
verdad solo para cuando x 1 x 2
bueno todos son iguales a 0 quiere decir
que la matriz multiplicada por el vector
es 0 y quiere decir entonces que el
espacio con perdón el espacio nulo sólo
puede ser el vector 0
y por lo tanto es inyectaba por otro
lado si es inyectaba el espacio no lo es
sólo el 0 esta multiplicación me da 0 lo
cual implica que estos vectores o bueno
esta esta expresión es 0 lo cual implica
que son linealmente independientes que
son una base y por lo tanto yo sé que es
un poquito cansado el rango de nuestra
matriz es n así que vas a hacer 11 si
sólo si el rango de tu matriz de tu
transformación es igual a n